when one died according to Egyptian
mythology before they could enter the
afterlife they would have to have their
heart weighed against the feather if the
scale was balanced then they were
allowed to pass on freely if their heart
weighed heavy they were deemed unworthy
of entry their soul was devoured by a
means they would suffer a second death
with no chance of a peaceful afterlife
amat or sometimes depicted as a goddess
of the underworld but she was never
really worshipped and her image was
thought to ward off evil she was most
commonly referred to as a demon a
malevolent supernatural being her name
roughly meaning devourer of souls or
devourer of the dead
um it has the head of a crocodile the
torso of a lioness or leopard and the
lower body and hind legs of a
hippopotamus now this may sound like a
strange mixture of animals but these
were the most ferocious and terrifying
creatures known to the ancient Egyptians
the Book of the Dead referred to Emmitt
as The Punisher and executioner
and she was often believed to be the
personification of divine retribution
and justice Amit would wait in the
judgment hall of Two Truths during the
weighing of the heart ceremony those who
were deemed not fit and to the afterlife
were given one last chance to explain
their life in front of a Cyrus and his
deity judges if they were still judged
to have led a sinful life
the Nesle would be given to emit there
are variations of habits where she did
not devour the souls of the sinful at
all instead the souls who were deemed
unworthy of the afterlife were thrown
into the lake of fire
she was believed to live nearby and
acted as the guardian of the lake of
fire
although Emmet's is rarely depicted as a
goddess and more commonly seen as a
demon who devours Souls she's in no way
inherently evil she acts to ensure order
enforce good and to ward off evil she
represents that every person is given a
chance to defend their actions before
final judgment
if you've enjoyed this video then please
consider leaving a thumbs up as it helps
promote the video and allows the channel
to grow if there's anything you'd like
to discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please let me know in the
comment section as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained
[Music]